thank you again to southwest medical for
sponsoring that segment and being one of
our community pride partners all right
let's move on here june is a time to
illuminate cancer survivors meryl cottby
the founder and creator of illuminate at
the strat is a two-time survivor and for
national cancer survivor month she is
sharing her inspiring story and adding a
new matinee for the community and
visitors to enjoy
now mural it's such a pleasure having
you on first and foremost i have to call
out your jacket your fabulous jacket
because that is not only a prop on the
show but it's also extremely fashionable
oh thank you it's so cute it's so cute
so let's talk about you created a
illuminate through your cancer journey
while you were on the cancer journey
let's talk about your story and just how
you got here
well i i've always been a dancer yeah
and i also write software so wow i was
going to dance professionally and then i
got cancer
the first time after that cancer i
couldn't dance anymore the way i was
used to dancing so i kind of
changed my direction and focused more on
the computer science part of my passions
and
a friend of mine was said why don't you
put your two loves together so i created
illuminate and it was amazing we were on
america's got talent we
you're sitting here right now
all around the world it was it's an
incredible journey and right when we
were at the peak i wasn't feeling quite
right and it ended up i got acute
myeloid leukemia
and so
the company kept going i'm really
fortunate for the people i have in the
illuminate family because they kept it
going while i went through i think five
rounds of chemo and a stem cell
transplant so i was away for a year
and now uh i'm back and one of the
things that was really inspiring was i
wanted to open a vegas show
and i even thought about it when i was
in the bed i was like what would the
vega show look like and now it actually
is a reality oh my gosh that is i'm
gonna grab beautiful um you're not only
radiating light on stage but you're
shining light in real life too um just
what can people expect from the show
what kind of show is it it is a very fun
show a lot of dancing a lot of amazing
lighting effects it goes with the music
you don't know when someone's gonna
appear or disappear people are in the
audience they're on stage there's
there's uh jazz there's classical ballet
there's hip-hop there's break dancing
and it's a story as well and beautiful
and characters so it's just it's a
really fun show and
it's for all ages and we have different
times we have like our matinee shows we
just added a wednesday matinee yes
that's part of we're celebrating this
month and that's part of what you guys
are doing right yeah we have our
wednesday matinee so you can bring the
family or you can just go on a wednesday
also our saturday and sunday matinees
but then
it's not just a family show everybody no
we've got some big news as of today
right
best date night yes according to the
best of las vegas how do you feel about
that i'm so excited
so besides
when can people join you guys when are
the other show times every night except
tuesday and sunday okay okay we have
evening shows yes at the start okay and
last but not least we have to know how
heavy is the jacket can we can we take
can i carry it a little bit i've heard
that it is extremely heavy you will be
amazed with the dancers oh my gosh
oh
whoa
okay this this is how do you know how
many pounds probably 20. and they're
they're dancing and singing and playing
in this they are beasts the dancers wow
okay you have to go see illuminate at
the strat where can people get tickets i
think you can go ireland.com you can go
to the strat website and
yeah okay oh my gosh well support the
show and support mural you are amazing
you're so beautiful
all right we'll be right back here in
las vegas now